honnêtement il manquait que des pomotes
et des cartables et on était au CO2
aujourd'hui le lâche c'est vous j'ai
l'honneur de demander des excuses
solennelles au rassemblement national
pour avoir employé le terme de lâche à
une personne qui a toujours fait preuve
de courage regarde ma bière le RN je
vais te retrouver dans la cour et on va
s'expliquer puisque c'est comme ça avec
mes potes ont s'en va
3 et bien qu'il aille tenté les fraises
en tout cas il y a de la matière pour
les humoristes quoi c'est ça c'est sûr
oui mais en fait ça nous fait pas
tellement rire d'ailleurs marié si vous
gagnez regardez on le voit le trophée
regardez c'est Kev Adams qu'il a là-haut
c'est ce trophée là qui sera à vous
enfin d'émission si vous gagnez
pas trop connaître ta maîtresse elle va
se dire là il est grand voilà la
maîtresse ça va être fière de toi Liam
tu es super beau hein tu te fais
confiance cette année tu travailles bien
tiens vous êtes là vous
on vous a pas vu jeudi collègue de
l'extrême droite vous étiez un
anniversaire vous préférez manger des
pépitos que de voter sur le projet de
loi de finance j'espère que le gâteau
était bon et les calcium le calcium est
à proximativement identique d'accord un
tout petit peu plus on doit être à 200
mg excusez-moi je suis en train de
rendre lamentablement
une petite boule petite moule avec une
petite frite bon bon appétit à vous nous
on se régale alors est-ce que vous
seriez prêt à tenir un mois sans alcool
je vais commencer avec vous frein Hermel
est-ce que j'ai une tête à suivre une
mode anglo-saxonne mais si c'est une
mode utile
c'est encore un coup de marketing donc
non non je ne fais pas le dry Jenny je
ne ferai pas le sober October j'en ai
marre d'être à la merci de ces gens qui
veulent contrôler ma vie en plus c'est
un point de vue
en période d'économie d'énergie et d'eau
on oublie la natation synchronisée
vive la natation sobriété
mais comme l'a dit Jack Lang qui dort
il ne faut pas paniquer
moi si je retiens quelque chose
d'aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il ne faut pas paniquer et moi
il est hors de question que je suis veut
cette mode et en plus en tant que bon
patriote français je soutiens la filière
vinicole française a commencé par le
bordeaux d'accord bien sûr mais c'est
pour soutenir les agriculteurs
oh là là quel ringard
quel ringard mais quel ringard mais quel
ringard mais je l'adore ouais bah bien
sûr
bonjour
[Applaudissements]
elle n'a pas vraiment inventé le fil à
couper le beurre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien le retour du vinyle quand
même vraiment c'est
dommage parce qu'il y en a certains qui
auraient peut-être sûrement une petite
valeur vous devriez regarder dans vos
cartons je peux pas c'est mon ex qu'ils
ont porté
[Applaudissements]
c'était l'époque où la gauche arrivait
au pouvoir où Jean-Paul Gaultier habillé
Madonna ou Earth Wind and Fire faisait
danser dans les boîtes les années 80
sont à l'honneur au Musée des Arts
Décoratifs de Paris chaque fois que je
rentre de chez Ikea ou que je rentre de
boîte de nuit c'est la même chose je
reviens avec un truc dont j'ai pas
spécialement besoin
[Rires]
que j'ai du mal que j'ai du mal à monter
et à la fin il me reste une petite vis
qui retenue par un couple de 84 ans qui
a tendu cet âge là pour se dire oui ce
weekend à Marseille après 40 ans d'amour
Gérard et Yolande qui se sont rencontrés
en 1983 pendant un voyage au Canada et
qui depuis ne se sont plus quittés
alors ils avaient déjà été en couple
avec quelques vous voyez ils sont très
amoureux et beaucoup de ferveur dans ce
baiser c'est la poutre de la pierre la
pierre
justement le sujet c'est les gourde donc
ça tombe bien entre le Sud-Ouest et le
centre au pardon excusez-moi on retrouve
sur les réseaux du Nord un temps
lumineux localement un temps lumineux
également dans le sud ce sont les aléas
du direct côté température
très douce sur le Nord grande douceur
dans le Sud-Ouest également avec 15
degrés à Toulouse et dans l'après-midi
les températures restent très douces